movies often missed their mark when it
comes to predicting the future I mean
where are flying cars
I was promised two flying cars having
said that there are several visionary
films like Minority Report and 2001 a
Space Odyssey that had managed to
predict some aspects of technological
innovation correctly from predicting VR
to self-driving cars here's a list of
movies that were ahead of their time
2001 a Space Odyssey is a sci-fi classic
that predicted numerous technological
innovations in the 1968 film we see
protagonist dr. Dave Bowen watching
videos on a tablet as he's eating a meal
aboard a space station Apple began
popularizing the tablet form factor when
it initially released the iPad in 2010
now we have several computing tablets
from Google Samsung Microsoft and more
2001 a Space Odyssey also brought us how
nine thousand one of the greatest
characters in sci-fi history the AI
assistant was capable of speech facial
recognition and more I know that you and
Frank were planning to disconnect me and
I'm afraid that's something I cannot
allow to happen it was also hell-bent on
killing humans
Apple famously released its own voice
assistant in 2011 with the launch of
Siri on iPhones now we have androids
okay google voice assistant and Amazon
Alexa the verdict is still out on
whether these AI assistants will try to
end us however
the 1982 sci-fi film Blade Runner is
greatly revered for a dafaq ative neon
depiction of the future massive digital
billboards playing videos were prominent
throughout the movie cyberpunk world
flash-forward to today and you have neon
digital billboards littered in areas
such as Times Square in New York and
Akihabara and Japan the first robot made
its debut on film before the term robot
was even coined in the Harry Houdini
black-and-white silent film the grim
game we see a humanoid looking automaton
named cute your since had numerous
robots throughout history but one
relatively recent one that caught the
attention of many is Sofia the human
looking robot was developed by Hong Kong
company Hanson robotics in the 1986
movie short circuit a tech company
prototypes robots for the US military
and ends up creating Johnny Five
now there are companies like Boston
Dynamics that are designing robots for
the US military
recently the tech company released a
video that went viral which showcased a
man trying to hold back a doglike robot
from opening a door despite some tugging
from the man which led to minor Robo
dismemberment the robot persisted until
it accomplished its mission cool or
creepy after being shot up
police officer Alex J Murphy finds
himself on the brink of death in Robocop
he's saved when the government revives
what's left of him and augments his body
with machinery
among his enhancements is a visor that
augments his vision it displays grids
which help bolsters aim and provides
additional info like mission objectives
and video feeds today we have augmented
reality headsets like Google glass and
AR advisors like hololens and magically
that are in development Back to the
Future Part 2 showcased self-lacing Nike
shoes fast forward to today you have
Nike shoes that look and function nearly
identical to the ones in the movie ok so
maybe this is a case where a movie
directly influences an invention ok I
actually started working on the shoes in
2005 but the battery technology wasn't
ready at the time and it required bulky
motors as mobile technology improved
Nike resumed to work on the shoes in
2012 before releasing them in 2016 just
about everybody wanted a hoverboard
after Marty McFly rode one in Back to
the Future Part 2 well we have them now
kinda tech company Hendo successfully
funded its hoverboard Kickstarter by
raising over $500,000
to the crowdfunding site it works too
I've tried it the only cab yet and it's
a major one is that it uses maglev
technology and thus requires a
conductive metal floor so unless you
have access to a copper skatepark you
probably won't get to ride one anytime
soon in total recall Arnold
Schwarzenegger character rides in a
self-driving Johnny cab the sci-fi taxi
featured a talking robot driver well
that's not a thing you can do today
self-driving cars are very real Google
has been testing them since 2009 and as
of June 2016 the tech giant's
self-driving vehicles drove over 1.7
million miles
many companies such as Nvidia Tesla and
uber are now working on self-driving car
technology aimed at the mass-market in
the 1992 film The Lawnmower Man dr.
Lawrence Angelo experiments on a
simple-minded gardener named Joe Smith
by strapping him to a virtual reality
headset the our contraption dramatically
improves Smith's cognitive abilities it
also inadvertently gives him telepathic
powers an evil mastermind subplot ensues
while we get to discover telepathic
capabilities we do have VR headsets like
the oculus rift psvr HTC vive in
addition to gaming VR headsets are also
helping autistic people develop better
social skills our assisting patients
overcome psychological issues like PTSD
in the 2002 released movie Minority
Report Tom Cruise waves his hands and
fingers in the air to control a gesture
base UI roughly eight years later in
2010 Microsoft would release the Kinect
with an infrared projector that would
allow the Xbox 360 to track user limbs
in three-dimensional space more advanced
subsequent devices like the leap motion
Microsoft's very own second generation
Kinect would later add higher fidelity
finger trick
for a much more exhaustive list of
movies that correctly predicted
technology make sure you head on over to
GameSpot comm thanks for watching
[Music]